monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
en france aujourd'hui on peut être
décapité seulement pour avoir fait un
cours d'instruction civique sur la
liberté d'expression en france
aujourd'hui des fatwas sont lancés et la
charia immédiatement exécuté mais cette
fois-ci quelque chose a changé parce que
les français sont passés presque
instantanément d'un état de sidération
un état de colère
ils demandent des comptes ils exigent
des résultats
tout simplement parce qu'ils sentent
confusément mais ils le sentent bien que
nous sommes en train de perdre le combat
contre le totalitarisme islamiste
faute de courage souvent faute aussi de
mener un combat global un combat global
contre l'islamisme ce toutes ses formes
sa forme violente ses formes rampante un
combat global aussi contre le désordre
migratoires qui en est l'un des terreaux
qui est un défi un obstacle à
l'assimilation de nos valeurs
républicaines
monsieur le premier ministre êtes vous
prêts êtes vous prêt à mener ce combat
qui doit être globale vous venez d'où
parlé d'un texte qui nous arrivera dans
cinq mois
au mois de février prochain ce texte si
comportera-t-il oui ou non des mesures
pour remédier à ce désordre migratoire
vous répondre la parole est à monsieur
le premier ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président
retailleau vous avez dit à juste titre
les français ont été sidérés les
français sont en colère
je crois que nous le sommes toutes et
tous
il n'y a pas de doute là-dessus et le
gouvernement de la république que j'ai
l'honneur de diriger il n'est pas
simplement sidéré ou en colère il est
déterminé et à la manoeuvre
déterminé et à la manoeuvre alors
j'entends je le regrette je vous le dis
tout de suite que nous soyons
questionner sur notre prétendue
inefficacité c'est sans doute le débat
démocratique et j'en accepte bien
entendu toutes les conditions
mais vous mesurez bien que les choses
sont difficiles et que d'autre part et
que d'autre part dans les finalités de
ceux qui combattent la république je le
répète il y a aussi la volonté de faire
éclater la communauté nationale
n'en doutez pas un seul instant
donc nous agissons nous agissons j'ai
ici le ministre de l'intérieur pourra y
revenir
tous ceux qui notamment sur le champ du
renseignement sur le champ du
renseignement vous avez parlé de
l'immigration mais je vous rappelle
je vous rappelle mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs que c'est fait et nous
avons des chiffres peuvent être commis
peuvent être le fait peuvent être
répandues par des personnes étrangères
mais également malheureusement par des
citoyens de la république donc l'autre
action elle est tous azimuts
elle est tous azimuts et il faut les
identifier c'est la première chose il
faut les identifier
pour les empêcher de passer à l'acte
nous avons renforcé considérablement
leur enseignement
nous allons nous attaquer aux effecteur
encore plus fort comme je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure
et nous prendrons toutes les mesures
vous m'entendez bien toutes les mesures
nous n'hésitons à aucun moment de le
faire notre main n'a jamais tremblé et
la mienne en particulier croyez le bien
ne tremblera pas monsieur le président
on recueille au mais monsieur le
président c'est vous c'est votre
gouvernement qui fait le lien entre
l'islamisme le terrorisme et
l'émigration puisque les premières
annonces du ministre de la ville
les premières annonces étaient des
expulsions d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière ce que vous ce que nous vous
demandons c'est le courage de réarmer la
république mais nous vous demandons
aussi de faire aimer la france
ne cédez pas ne cédez pas vraiment ne
cédez pas à la tentation qu'est la
tentation si française de la pénitence
perpétuel il faut faire aimer la france
ne désignez pas la france comme un
coupable perpétuel ne faites pas comme
le président de la république en
indiquant que la france est coupable du
crime contre l'humanité le pire des
crimes
monsieur le premier ministre oui il faut
réarmer la république il faut s'y faire
aimer la france rôle vont ensemble
l'étendard de nos couleurs de nos
valeurs rôles vont ensemble aussi
l'étendard de la fierté française
merci
[Applaudissements]